[Music]
today's question comes from tony in new
jersey i know dave teaches about
investing in the four mutual fund
categories through a 401k or ira but i
prefer investing in single stocks on my
own i deposit money regularly in my
robinhood account and it seems to be
doing pretty well what's the downside to
this type of investing as long as i'm
contributing from every paycheck
this one we're exploring on the fine
print dave oh we're yeah this is going
to be a whole episode on diy investing
on robin hood a lot of stuff in the news
about robin hood and uh this is an area
where you know people feel like they're
they can be tricky they go well you know
i get dave's stuff it's old school it's
it's a little boring it's it's a
tortoise
but dave i've made some good money off
some single stocks this year tesla's
been doing great i'm throwing some money
into tesla and the problem is uh until
you touch the hot stove you feel like
you know what you're doing cooking in
the kitchen
and so my worry for tony is that if you
want to mess with single stocks after
you've done the 15 retirement and this
is fun money for you and this is a real
small percentage of your portfolio
that's fine but don't put your all of
your eggs in this single stock basket
that frightens me yeah
the bible says spread your portions to
seven yes to eight for disaster may come
upon the land
that's a biblical version of
diversification
leaving all your eggs in one basket some
idiot
on wall street is twirling the basket
and you're betting everything on that
one idiot
that makes you
not smart
diversification lowers risk and
increases rates of return over a long
period of time it's a standard
portfolio management process that has
been used in financial planning for
decades and it outperforms the single
stock investor
not maybe not on the short term but
single stock investors are a lot like
fishermen all they talk about was the
time they caught a boatload they never
talk about the time they went out there
and lost everything
they never talked about the time that it
went through the floor and then
everything got messed up because some
idiot was playing margin on them
and so you you tony you're asking for it
you're playing russian roulette with
your money you're asking for it and
you're gonna get your head taken off son
the market's going to correct your
little butt
and it's just a matter of when and then
you're going to have an ouchy moment and
you're going to know what george and i
are talking about
diversification lowers risk spreading
your money across many many investments
like in a mutual fund versus being in
single stocks you are asking for trouble